yeah i guess youtube algorithm says in
order to maintain
monetization um i can't use bad words in
the first minute
of my video so i'm gonna say i look like
hell sorry i look like hell today hell's
not a bad word it's a place but it's
been a particularly
bad allergy day but we take a break from
the greatest
show on earth to talk about mando
because you know
we want to and in today's episode of the
episodic adventures of mandalorian man
delorean crash lands on a planet and
adventures continue that that's the
episodic adventure for today actually i
dug the beginning when he was still on
tatooine because it shows that
bounty hunters and other nerf herders
are looking for baby yoda and they
should be
we heard that was gonna happen so it was
actually cool to see it happen gonna be
honest i feel kind of mean cause i'm
sure she's so nice that's what people
say right before they bag on a character
it's like i'm sure the actor is so nice
i'm not a fan of her character
just her and her pit droids just anyhow
we leave tattooing and mando comes
across a couple of x-wing fighters from
the new republic and new republics like
hey you're either with us or against us
pretty intrusive stuff you know he
wanted to be like i'm not with you or
against you i'm not
with the empire anyhow just let me be on
my way fight your war
mando's like wait a minute what would
malcolm reynolds do
hide on this planet so that's pretty
much the gist of this episode of the
mandalorian mandalorian kind of crash
lands well i mean he lands with
grace-ish and then falls through and his
ship kind of gets trashed
and he has to take on one of the most
vicious predators in a galaxy far
far away no not spiders baby yoda that's
what i learned baby yoda is the monster
under the bed for many children
in this galaxy far far away because he's
basically acting like a taxi to this
gecko mom and this gecko mom's like hey
this is my jar full of babies like she
hacked into the droid and used the voice
to communicate with mandalorian and
really stresses hey
these babies these eggs are all i have
in which baby otis like
yeah i've been eating your children and
i will continue to eat your children
because your children taste
good glad we can humanize your eggs in
this episode
to make me eating them all the more
vicious then gekko mom finds a hot
spring on this cold planet
smart you know cold-blooded creature
earth rules apply seem like a smart idea
and then baby yoda's like
children but baby yoda can't eat those
children so baby yoda's like hey
spider eggs you know what that means
children ollie these ones
and all the spiders are like dude what
the [ __ ] so now they have to take on a
family of angry spiders
because they hate one of their kids i
didn't know yodas were so
metal like it really does give more
gravity to yoda's character to know that
he's essentially
from a race of
galactic predators galactic cannibals of
children i will say though mando's like
oh i'm gonna use my blast room like dude
you have a flamethrower like i don't
know when i saw the eggs hatching
and it looked like it was going down if
this was a video game i'd be like okay
flamethrower's the first thing take out
all the tiny ones
then take out the big ones with the
blasters that got pretty intense they
were invading the ship and
he does finally use the flamethrower at
a point
he does in the cave and then he finally
is like all right i'll do it here in the
ship but then the republic saves his ass
which is great until they don't i mean
you see lasers shooting these big
spiders and you know you're like oh this
is the x-wing guys and it totally is and
they're like amanda you're wanted
but also you've kind of you've done some
good for us
so we won't arrest you but they kind of
do the the batman
from batman begins where it's like i'm
not going to kill you
but i don't have to save you and they
just peace out
you know like they didn't know how fixed
or not
fixed his ship was the spider punctured
the window i mean it didn't look like he
was getting off that rock so for all
they knew they were like hey we just
saved your ass
just to watch you freeze to death but
entertainment is pretty sparse out here
and that just seems like a good time
watching a mandalorian freeze to death i
mean what if he didn't have his ship
all repaired what if he was like dude
you're leaving me to die you
dicks who knows maybe they were like we
know who your cargo is we know the child
we know who you have with you one of
those yodas ate bobby's son timmy just
sleeping in his bed grabbed him
sucked him under ate him from toe to
head baby you hold up more like baba
yaga
you and your bobby yoga you can go ahead
and freeze it out here but turns out
mando repaired his firefly-ish
chip and when they fly off and that's
the end of the episode
endo gets off the ice planet with baba
yaga and worst gekko mom ever
apparently i don't know you would think
that that gecko mom would know exactly
how many eggs are in that jar
she doesn't know about four of them are
missing doesn't question what happened
just for good measure at the end
last shot is baby yoda has one he's like
anyhow episodic adventures yes and this
is as episodic as they come and that's
what there is to say about this episode
and my allergies are still killing me so
the mandalorian season 2 episode 2 or
chapter 10
is they call them different things new
episode of mandalorian
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you